I'm what you would call a collector of
bootleg Pokemon games pokemon diamond
the Jade chaos black etc it's amazing
the frequency which you can find them at
pawn shops goodwill flea markets and
such they're generally fun even if they
are unplayable which they often are the
mistranslations of poor quality make
them unintentionally humorous i've been
able to find most of the ones i played
online but there's one that i haven't
seen any mention of i bought it at a
flea market about five years ago here's
a picture of the cartridge case anyone
recognizes it
unfortunately when I moved two years ago
I lost the game so I can't provide you
with any screen caps sorry the game
started with the familiar knee Torino
and Gengar intro of the red and blue
version however the press Start screen
had been altered red was there but the
Pokemon didn't cycle through it also
said black version under the Pokemon
logo upon selecting new game the game
started the Professor Oak's speech and
it quickly became evident that the game
is essentially pokemon red version after
selecting your starter if you looked at
your Pokemon you had in addition to
Bulbasaur Charmander or squirtle another
pokemon ghost the Pokemon was level 1
it had the sprite of the ghosts that are
encountered in lavender town before
obtained the Silph scope it had one
attack curse now I know there's a real
move named curse the attack didn't exist
in generation 1 so bears was hacked and
defending Pokemon were unable to attack
ghost
it would only say they were too scared
to move when the move curse was used in
battle the screen would cut to black
the cry of the defending Pokemon would
be heard but it was distorted played in
a much lower pitch than usual the battle
screen would then reappear and the
defending Pokemon would be gone if used
in a battle against the trainer when the
pokeballs representing their Pokemon
would appear in the corner
they would have one fewer poker ball man
vacation was that the pokemon died
what's even stranger is that after
defeating a trainer and seeing red
received $200 for winning the battle
commands would appear again if you
selected run the battle would end as it
normally does you could also select
curse if did upon returning to the
overworld the trainer sprite will be
gone after leaving and re-entering the
area a spot where the trainer had been
would be replaced with a tombstone like
the ones at lavender Tower
the move curse wasn't usable in all
instances it would fail against ghost
Pokemon it would also fail if it was
used against the trainers that you would
have to face again such as the arrival
or Giovanni it was usable in your final
battle against the myeloma I figured
this was a gimmick of the game allowing
you to use previously owned capturable
ghosts and because the curse made the
game so easy I essentially used it
throughout the whole adventure the game
changed quite a bit after defeating the
Elite Four after viewing the Hall of
Fame which consists of ghosts and a
couple of Pokemon I use for HMS the
screen cut the black
a box appeared with the words many years
later that then cut the lavender town an
old man was standing looking at
tombstones he then realized this man was
your character the man moved at only
half of your normal walking speed you no
longer had any Pokemon with you not even
ghost who up to this point have been
impossible to remove from your party
through depositing in the PC the
overworld
was entirely empty there was no people
at all there were still tombstones of
the trainers that used curse on
you could go pretty much anywhere in the
overworld at this point though your
movement was limited by the fact he had
no Pokemon to use a gems and regardless
of where you went the music of lavender
town continued on an infinite loop after
wandering for a while I found that if
you go through diglettz cave one of the
cuttable bushes that normally blocks the
path and the other side is no longer
there allowing me to advance and return
to Pallet Town
upon entering your house and going to
the exact tile where you start the game
the screen would cut the black
then a sprite of Caterpie appeared it
was replaced by wheedle and then Pidgey
I soon realized as the Pokemon
progressed from Rattata to Blastoise
that these were all of the Pokemon that
I had used curse on after the end of my
rivals team a youngster appeared and
then a bug catcher
these were the trainers I had cursed
throughout the sequence the lavender
town music was playing but it was slowly
decreasing in pitch by the time your
rival appeared on screen it was a little
more than a demonic rumble another cut
to black a few moments later the battle
screen suddenly appeared
your trainer sprite was now that of an
old man the same one as the one who
teaches you how to catch a Pokemon in
Viridian City ghost appears on the other
side along with the words ghost wants to
fight
he couldn't use items and you had no
Pokemon if he tried to run you couldn't
escape the only option was a fight using
fight would immediately cause you to
struggle which didn't affect ghosts but
it did chip off a bit of your own HP
when it was ghosts turned to attack that
would simply say dot dot dot eventually
when your HP reached a critical point
ghost would finally used curse the
screen cut to black for a final time
regardless of the buttons pressed you
were permanently stuck in this black
screen
at this point the only thing you could
do was turn the Gameboy off when you
played again new game was the only
option the game and erased the file I
played through this hacked game many
many times and every time the game ended
with this sequence several times I
didn't use ghost at all though he was
impossible to remove from the party in
these cases it didn't show any Pokemon
or trainers and simply cut to the
climactic battle with ghost I'm not sure
what the motives were behind the creator
of this hack it wasn't widely
distributed so it was presumably not for
monetary gain
it was very well done for a bootleg it
seems he was trying to convey a message
though it seems I'm the sole receiver of
this message I'm not entirely sure when
it was inevitable 'ti of death the
pointlessness sub perhaps he was simply
trying to morbidly inject death and
darkness into a children's care
regardless his children's game has made
me think and it has made me cry
you